SPEAKER 1: We begin
with a problem.
Alice and Bob live
in tree forts which
are far apart, with no
line of sight between them.
And they need to communicate.
So they decide to run a
wire between the two houses.
They pull the wire tight and
attach a tin can to each end,
allowing them to send their
voices faintly along the wire.
SPEAKER 2: Can you hear me?
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 3: I can hear
you, but just barely.
SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: However,
there is a problem.
Noise.
Whenever there is
a high wind, it
becomes impossible to hear
the signal over the noise.
So they need a way to increase
the energy level of the signal
to separate it from the noise.
This gives Bob an idea.
They can simply
pluck the wire, which
is much easier to
detect over the noise.
But this leads to a new problem.
How do they encode their
messages as plucks?
Well, since they want to play
board games across a distance,
they tackle the most
common messages first.
The outcome of two dice rolls.
In this case, the
messages they are sending
can be thought of as a
selection from a finite number
of symbols.
In this case, the 11
possible numbers, which we
call a discrete source.
At first, they decide to
use the simplest method.
They send the result as
the number of plucks.
So to send a three,
they send three plucks.
Nine is nine plucks.
And 12 is 12 plucks.
However, they soon
realize that this
takes much longer
than it needs to.
From practice, they find that
their maximum pluck speed
is two plucks per second.
Any faster and they
will get confused.
So two plucks per
second can be thought
of as the rate, or capacity
for sending information
in this way.
And it turns out that
the most common roll
is a seven, so it
takes 3.5 seconds
to send the number seven.
[WIRE VIBRATIONS]
Alice then realizes
they can do much better
if they change their
coding strategy.
She realizes that the odds
of each number being sent
follows a simple pattern.
There is one way to roll
a two, two ways to rule
is three, three ways
to roll a four, four
ways to roll a five,
five ways to roll a six,
and six ways to rule a
seven, the most common.
And five ways to roll an
eight, four ways for a nine,
and so on, back to
one way for a 12.
And this is a graph showing the
number of ways each result can
occur, and the
pattern is obvious.
So now let's change
the graph to number
of plucks versus each symbol.
She proceeds by mapping the
most common number, seven,
to the shortest
signal, one pluck.
She then proceeds to the
next most probable number,
and if there is a tie,
she picks one at random.
In this case, she selects
six to be two plucks,
and then eight to be three
plucks, and then back to five
to be four plucks, and
nine as five plucks,
and back and forth
until we reach
12, which is assigned
to 11 plucks.
Now the most common
number, seven,
can be sent in less than a
second, a huge improvement.
This symbol change allows
them to send more information
in the same amount
of time on average.
In fact, this coding strategy is
optimal for this simple example
in that it's impossible for
you to come up with a shorter
method of sending two dice
rolls using identical plucks.
However, after playing with
the wire for some time,
Bob hits on a new idea.
[WIRE VIBRATIONS]